in 1994 french director luke besson
unveiled his latest movie leon the
professional this action thriller
centers on the titular hitman played by
jon renau who ends up taking a young
girl named matilda under his wing after
her family is killed the actress who
played leon's protege was none other
than natalie portman and her decision to
join the production at just 11 years old
marks the beginning of her big screen
journey portman's portrayal of matilda
didn't go unnoticed and with each
subsequent role she took her stock in
hollywood grew dramatically higher it
was during the 2000s that she really
made waves however with movies such as v
for vendetta and garden state the next
decade kept her busy too with projects
including black swan thor and
annihilation these days natalie portman
is a household name having taken on
several career defining projects earned
numerous awards and used her platform to
spread awareness on issues near and dear
to her however thanks to one now beloved
science fiction blockbuster all of this
success could very well have never come
to fruition 1999 was a huge year for
natalie portman seeing it was a year she
joined the cast of star wars episode 1
the phantom menace portman starred as
padme
the queen of naboo and an eventual key
figure in the galactic senate as well as
the future wife of anakin skywalker and
the mother of their twins luke and leia
naturally landing a job like that should
be the single greatest korea move she
could ever make right well not exactly
since george lucas's second star wars
trilogy was met with some seriously
harsh reactions from critics not to
mention the fact that the fandom
fractured with each passing installment
putting immense pressure on the cast and
crew for natalie portman specifically
revenge of the sith came scarily close
to ending her run on the silver screen
she did what she could with lucas's
notoriously weak dialogue and tried to
give a convincing performance but
evidently it wasn't enough for most
audiences by her own admission to new
york magazine in 2014 she struggled to
find acting parts in the wake of her
stint in a galaxy far far away noting
that star wars led many in the industry
to believe she was a bad actress portman
recalled i was in the biggest grossing
movie of the decade and no director
wanted to work with me one likely reason
for natalie portman losing hollywood's
good graces post-star wars had to do
with the direction of padme amidala's
story in the phantom menace she was
introduced as the intelligent determined
leader of naboo who fought back
valiantly against the separatist
invaders then in attack of the clones
she showed that she wasn't afraid to
take the fight to her enemies on the
battlefield of geonosis or break every
rule in the book to be with her true
love by the time revenge of the sith
rolled around however much of padme's
character development and personality
had suddenly disappeared as a result of
padme's reduced role in the story
portman didn't have a lot to sink her
teeth into during filming on revenge of
the sith her work amounted to delivering
a few lines now and again and crying
before somehow dying of sadness
something the film itself did a poor job
of explaining the movie effectively
relegated padme to a plot device
designed to sell movie goers on anakin's
transformation into darth vader that's
certainly not a good look for portman
herself of course and things weren't
helped along by the fact that many of
her better scenes were cut in particular
once a plot involving padme helping
found the rebel alliance wound up on the
cutting room floor we are not separators
trying to leave the republic we are
loyalists trying to preserve democracy
in the republic i can't believe it has
come to this it's plain enough to see
that the actress and her character both
got the short end of the stick
thankfully it didn't take too long for
the stigma of revenge of the sith to
wear off and for acting giggs to come
natalie portman's way once again her
career is still very much intact and
will hopefully remain as searched well
into the future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you